[Musique]
peut-être de marque différente sur les
scènes de concert mais tout ça sort
souvent la même marque beaucoup c'est un
peu comme les voitures ou les escalades
les escalators on a la même chose
absolument partout voilà
et dans ce temps-là la facture évoluait
surtout on inventé on cherche de
nouveaux teintes dans tous les domaines
instrumentaux et donc là ça on a une
très très grande variété aussi les bois
de construction correspondent aux
origines géographiques et traditions
il y a certainement des tendances
nationales qui ont avoir avec la
personnalité comme vraiment dans la
cuisine
on construisait et on faisait un accent
son âme et aussi avec les matériaux
qu'on trouvait sur place voilà
des époques différentes alors là ils se
sont tous des copies sauf l'un d'entre
eux
les trois grands classes ici sont des
clavecin
d'esthétique allemande
qui est basé sur un clavecin du début du
XVIIIe
de Berlin d'un facteur qui s'appelait
Michael
que Marc a bien connu et chez qui il a
été réceptionné un clavecin qui était
commandé par la Cour de cutten voilà
donc c'est des choses qui sont vraiment
concentrés sur un style particulier donc
il y a une recherche de et c'est
peut-être la particularité de jouer du
club simple ne jouez pas qu'au piano
c'est de rechercher
ce que l'instrument peut nous apprendre
justement parce que il y avait cette
interaction très forte entre un
composite le compositeur et les facteurs
ils travaillaient ensemble ils discutait
il cherchaient des choses il se
critiquer bah qu'il était terriblement
critique enfin il était craint justement
pour ces expertises tout ça avançait
parallèlement
et donc les instruments ont des
caractéristiques propres qui nous
apprennent quelque chose sur la musique
voilà donc c'est une façon de se
rapprocher des
œuvres des œuvres
justement alors le clavecin dans votre
vie d'abord je crois que c'est vous avez
été fasciné je vais je crois que vous
avez entendu Richter jouer le clavier
bien
tempérées
et donc ça c'est au piano ça c'est au
piano mais pourquoi pas le piano ce qui
est le plus important dans l'histoire
c'est quand même l'esprit qu'on dit mais
donc si parler de Richter Richter il
mettait le sentiment certainement
religieux spirituelle
il essayait de respecter ce qui était là
le texte d'accord ce qui pensait être le
texte mais donc il disait quelque chose
de très vrai qui parle qui nous parle
fort et qui nous parle toujours
aujourd'hui moi je suis né j'ai commencé
la musique à un moment où il y avait cet
intérêt pour le passer
chez certains interprètes qui voulaient
faire table rase de toutes les
traditions de toutes les strates de
tradition alors si on parle de bague
depuis le 18e siècle mais qui sont à mon
avis plutôt une sorte de dérive lente
parce qu'on oublie parce que les
pratiques changent et après on pense
qu'on respecte une tradition mais ça ne
veut plus rien dire
oui c'est ça
qu'il fallait revenir il fallait essayer
de comprendre une correspondait trop
loin on est trop loin maintenant quand
Chopin je me bats au piano bon il se
basait aussi sur une tradition très
récente encore du fils de bac
de rencontrer etc
maintenant on est tellement loin mais
aussi on joue la musique des trois
quatre siècles on l'adore la vénère
enfin tous ceux qui l'aiment
et c'était pas le cas dans les époques
d'inquiétants aussi pourquoi
on s'accroche comme ça c'est chose
anciennes qu'on trouve immense
incroyable et le son voilà donc je
dirais pas plus c'est
un peu inquiétant aussi oui peut-être
peut-être pour moi en tout cas comme
musicien comme homme c'est quelque chose
d'inquiétant que je suis vive dans le
passé
parce que j'y trouve une richesse
quand on parle de bac le clavecin c'est
des musiques écrites pour le clavecin ah
oui alors
particulièrement une pièce
intempéries les deux livres sont des
œuvres qui ont été composées pour
instruments à clavier de toutes sortes
de toutes sortes c'est à dire il n'y a
pas d'indication sur la partition bac a
seulement par deux ou trois fois indiqué
sur des partitions éditées parce qu'il a
édité à cet arbre dans sa vie finalement
et il a pas édité le cœur intempéries
pendant qu'il n'a pas considéré que
c'était si important ou la BAC
considérée que ça devait être diffuser
parce qu'il pensait que ce serait pas
compris je ne sais pas mais il a pas
choisi
la Bible il a une découverte presque
après quoi absolument il a édité
il a édité certaines et là des fois il a
spécifié pendant les variations
goldennes que vous avez enregistré deux
fois je crois deux fois oui oui
là c'est une oeuvre qui est composée
spécifiquement enfin il décrite pour un
clavecin à deux claviers et dans son
écriture
il y a certaines variations pas toutes
qui nécessitent de clavier alors on se
débrouille sur un clavier on se
débrouille mais c'est parce qu'il a
voulu et on perd aussi certaines
couleurs qui sont induites par
l'utilisation
pourquoi il y a deux claviers sur
certains pas sur tout les
instruments mais un mot quand même donc
vous vous êtes vous êtes l'enfant
très célèbre Richter et votre mère aussi
était peintre je crois
ma mère était peintre mes parents se
sont connus
aux Beaux-Arts à Budapest tous les deux
étaient peintres et mon père
a pris le dessus comme souvent
de peintre
toujours très important et pour mon père
c'était justement la musique de Bach et
ce qui a précédé aussi ah oui voilà
une tradition réelle parce que bon
oui certainement en tout cas tout ça
toute ma vie ça ça
c'est plus qu'un lien avec cette
éducation parce que tout est dans
l'éducation si on est dans un dans un
milieu on le subit on le rejette ou au
contraire on est on est nourri donc ce
qui a été mon cas mais bon je m'en
culturel c'est très important parce que
c'est une c'est une appréhension de
l'art en général
comme un comme un bain c'est-à-dire je
suis désolé
de la musique
on était oui dans la famille on était
fasciné par là ça veut dire énormément
de de
place d'autant plus qu'on habitait dans
un tout petit village enseignant voilà
mais à l'époque c'était c'était comme à
1000 km c'était vraiment la campagne
il y avait des artistes surtout des du
côté de la peinture une galerie
qui venaient du côté de la musique peu à
peu quand on les frères et moi parce que
mon frère
de la musique
vous êtes quatre
les trois Ford de la musique vous avez
fondé un groupe
oui alors on joue ensemble
trio comme ça puis des fois avec des
invités pour parce que la partition
nécessaire violon et puis sinon on a peu
à peu enfin c'est surtout moins
construit un petit orchestre qui qui
varie en fonction des
œuvres mais aujourd'hui bon c'est peu en
retardisme de Jérôme il est aussi
passionné par les pianos anciens
d'accord donc il a une collection de
pianos du 18e et début du 19e siècle
c'est son
différent que les gens qui sont fascinés
par Shakespeare on parle Platon ou les
gens qui vivent dans la culture
égyptienne antique ou c'est assez de cet
ordre là on peut trouver quelque chose
d'extraordinaire dans toutes les
cultures mais il faut dire que la
musique
occidentale
savante c'est une comme une histoire
absolument extraordinaire ce qui a eu
ici entre le Moyen-âge et 17e 18e bac
montéverti Mozart Brahms de Bussy c'est
quelque chose c'est quand même une
aventure ça aurait pu ça aurait pu se
passer autrement la musique occidentale
c'est quand même quelque chose tout à
fait extraordinaire justement quand vous
regardez ou pas de
beaux-arts de Lucie
vous voyez une filiation
dans ces elle est cette
ne serait-ce que parce que lui-même
était un des rares d'ailleurs il était
beaucoup plus attaché
à la tradition et respectueuse de ce qui
a précédé et respectueux de ses
collègues même si il y était extrêmement
inférieure mais mais il était
extrêmement curieux d'esprit des enfants
si au pied des partitions
italiens et il a étudié la musique qu'il
a précédé la musique il était puis sa
famille d'une famille de musiciens avec
de grands musiciens beaucoup moins
connus que lui avant on connaissait fils
mais c'est en fait les ondes des grands
musiciens et il était oui oui facilité
par il était très très fier de sa
famille musicienne voilà mais tout ça
pour dire que lui était comme ça et puis
après il était considéré de toute
manière par tous ceux qui ont suivi j'ai
comme le plus grand comme le plus grand
un peu à peu mais après il était
fasciné Beethoven et Chopin on sait tous
les jours se lever le le matin et jouer
un peu le bac pour se mettre en route et
ça n'a pas changé depuis les suivants
pareil ceux qui ont commencé à l'éditer
à le transcrire
donc ce lien bien sûr il existe même si
la musique s'est transforme et
extrêmement
qu'est-ce que vous diriez c'est parce
que je sais pas comme ça au vu de enfin
ça me parle de lui aussi mais une sorte
de perfection mais
les constructions
nous on peut pas admettre comprendre
c'est à tomber sa chaise c'est insensé
intellectuellement insensé et d'autant
que lui ça on le sait on l'a appris
parce que c'est un compositeur chez qui
tous les toutes les strates sont
superposées mais y compris des des
strates philosophiques religieux
symbolique et tout ça et mêler là-dedans
d'une façon tellement géniale c'était un
esprit
supérieur mais il nous a rien dit il y a
sa musique qui effectivement a toujours
été entendu comme une musique
d'équilibre d'ordre et qui a toujours
été comprise comme une musique des sens
religieuse on l'a toujours tout le monde
l'a pensé tout le monde décrit comme ça
mais finalement avec les années les
siècles on a trouvé dans la partition
énormément de symboles cachés de choses
qui vont totalement dans cette direction
là c'est à dire qu'il y avait une
symbolique des noms donc ils comptaient
les mesures y construisaient ça comme un
château ses oeuvres comme château c'est
incroyable et cet ordre il la recherche
c'est pour lui de contraintes qui se
donnait à la terrible terrible il a les
il reprenait ces manuscrits etc jusqu'à
ce qu'il arrive au bon nombre de mesures
parce qu'il y avait toujours la Trinité
le 3 qui était là dedans il y avait son
propre chiffre à lui il y avait toutes
ces choses là il le faisait comme un
dialogue entre Dieu et lui il va
c'est-à-dire c'était pas nous on devait
entendre la musique et subir et entendre
cet ordre magnifique
bon pour lui l'illustration de la de la
perfection de la création c'était ça et
lui devait l'illustrer je pense c'est un
peu personnel mais à partir de ça
considérait presque comme un disciple
qui devait
en musique porter
parole et j'ai une thèse moi mais je
voulais développerai pas ici qui se
considérait comme celui qui devait
racheter Judas
c'est vrai qu'on est dans une époque
aussi où les artistes en panne on peut
parler de peinture tout à l'heure aussi
se considère que la beauté c'est dur
aussi
autre chose
pour moi est sacré par essence
en lui-même et pardon mais vous qui
possédez parfaitement bac
vous jouez beaucoup dans des concerts
vous l'avez enregistré vous avez
notamment parlé des variations Golbey
quand vous rejoignez vous jouez
aujourd'hui parfois ça vous arrive de de
prendre des choses encore tout le temps
tout le temps oui oui c'est on découvre
toujours quelque chose mais quand vous
dites je
maîtrise pas du tout mais personne
des initiateurs ce mouvement de
justement
nettoyage et cette compréhension des
compositeurs dans leur époque qui
disaient Bach et Mozart donc on
considère comme les plus grands sont les
compositeurs les plus sous-estimés de
l'histoire de la musique
parce que sous entendez
on peut pas les comprendre donc on ne
peut pas les comprendre
on ne peut pas aller au bout
complexe ce sont des génies qui ont été
plus loin que ce qu'on pense donc on en
perçoit quelque chose
on aperçoit quelque chose mais il faut
toujours chercher et les études c'est
toute manière un but qui est et vous
continuez et les
entre les spécialistes de la musique
baroque je vais vous dire c'est comme
vous l'êtes vous êtes des musiciens vous
êtes aussi des chercheurs
oui parce qu'il faut oui
enfin ce qu'on appelle la musique
ancienne
qui ont ça c'est jamais vraiment arrêté
il y a toujours eu des clavecin ici ou
là dans des salons où venaient des gens
des grands compositeurs des grands
artistes mais bon évidemment c'était
très très limité justement
vous êtes vous êtes à côté de
Fontainebleau dans cet enfance il y a un
piano chez vous non il y a il y a eu le
premier instrument était une épinette
épinette c'est quoi une épinette c'est
un petit clavecin en fait c'est un
clavecin qui est dimension enfin qui est
en elle d'oiseau comme ça ou alors qui
est octogonale avec le clavier et les
cordes dans ce sens-là mais c'est un
petit instrument domestique pas
d'ailleurs mais il y en a plein sur les
tableaux oui italien et puis à se
dériver qui est le virginal
qui est la version flamande et qui
plutôt carré ou rectangulaire et il y en
a plein sur les tableaux de fermer par
exemple dans la dans la peinture
hollandaise et flamande il y en a plein
mais c'est l'instrument que les gens
avaient facilement à la maison ils
avaient moins facilement un clavecin et
là vous avez commencé à étudier en
autodidacte
au tout début oui
perdu à la campagne comme ça en réalité
le beau j'ai mis mes mains sur le
clavier comme ça quoi mais j'ai venais
après mes frères donc j'avais les
modèles aussi mais je dois dire que le
lycée
à partir de la 6e nous a été d'une
grande aide parce qu'on apprenait encore
un peu la musique au lycée
il y avait des cours de musique on
jouait d'un instrument extrêmement
simple à jouer le plus facile à jouer
qui est la flûte à bec ça a beaucoup
agacé des générations de gens parce que
la flûte à becs
comme les autres et qu'il était
magnifiquement joué par des grands
musiciens et ben il y en a dans les
cantades de bac
il suffit tous les instruments sont
bourse ils sont bien joués
et aux jouets la flûte à peine donc on
apprenait les notes de la portée voilà
c'était très simple et après il fallait
prendre les deux clés le clavier peu à
peu comme ça mais au moins il y avait
quelque chose encore au lycée et nous
évidemment on
était
on a pu apprendre ça parce qu'il y avait
derrière une influence déjà mais
en fait on a on a commencé à prendre
vraiment la musique au lycée et puis
après des stages des choses comme ça et
quand est-ce que vous découvrez que ça
sera l'instrument de votre vie au fond
très vite
je crois
mais parce que c'était surtout la
musique
de Bach
essentiellement qui était important pour
moi dès l'enfance et le Cloud il allait
avec c'était son instrument et il y
avait des commentaires de grands
interprètes au club 5 qui jouait et donc
je suis allé dans cette direction là
vous avez de grands professeurs
Léonard le plus grand enfin
qui était hollandais hollandais
et vous allez Hollande non oui c'est pas
une autre particularité de mon parcours
c'est que je suis jamais rentré dans un
conservatoire je suis jamais inscrit
conservatoire réellement donc je sais
pas quelle est la vie conservatoire avec
les examens les différentes
catégories de
de domaine qu'on apprend là la
régularité des leçons enfin tout ce
cette ruche qui est conservatoire je
connais pas en fait aujourd'hui un petit
peu comme professeur après mais
brièvement
et donc
j'étais très jeune et puis donc il y
avait ce
musicien fantastique que je voulais
approcher
Amsterdam donc je prenais le train j'ai
appris
il m'a pris sous un comme beaucoup
d'autres parce qu'il est les gens
venaient du Japon des États-Unis
d'Amérique du Sud pour lui parce que
c'était le le grand
mais c'était un mouvement qui était
encore à ses débuts et ça concernait
assez peu de gens
et c'était en dehors du système encore
totalement et c'était même c'était même
décrié parce qu'il y a des pays où ça
prenait Hollande
en Autriche un peu en Allemagne
difficilement sur la tradition était
tellement forte vis-à-vis du mal à
changer
mais en France c'était le bon les
commentateurs journalistes le public
était encore très hostile à ça de jouer
sur ses instruments du grenier comme on
disait
dans les années 70 il y avait des
émissions en France Musique où il y a
des tenants du pour ils étaient très peu
et il y avait les tenants du contre
c'était des bagarres et c'était comme ça
il faut jouer avec les instruments de
notre époque quoi oui mais aussi on
redécouvrait des instruments qu'on
n'avait pas joué depuis trois siècles
alors bon on est un clavier ça se voit
un clavier ça s'accorde et ça se joue au
pianiste jouer là
c'est pas c'est pas si compliqué mais
quand vous commencez à l'utiliser des
instruments en bois comme les flûtes
qui sont différentes des instants
aujourd'hui mais surtout les cuivres
c'est-à-dire les trompettes
qui n'ont pas de trous pas de piston on
change la hauteur des sons uniquement
les lèvres et bacs à écrit des
partitions monstrueuses pour cet
instrument mais parce qu'il avait un ou
deux solistes fantastique
oui mais trois siècles après il fallait
apprendre ça et au début c'était un peu
un peu négligé donc il y avait il
fallait accepter une imperfection
technique pour le plaisir de retrouver
des sons qu'on a qui étaient différents
intéressants mais qui est aussi
s'intégrer très bien dans la composition
des équilibres instrumentaux c'est un
orchestre plus petit des instants de vos
cours plus petits et tout ça c'est
équilibré mieux
évidemment est-ce qu'il y avait une
communauté au fond des musiciens qui qui
aimaient redécouvrir cette musique vous
avez joué par exemple avec Jordy Saval
des gens comme ça enfin est-ce qu'il y
avait une communauté de penser de de il
y avait beaucoup de découverte de cette
musique au fond mais c'est à dire
c'était des gens qui ont fait ce trajet
de d'abandonner ce qu'il connaissait ce
qu'ils avaient appris pour essayer de
tout changer de réapprendre autrement
donc c'était des gens intéressants je
crois des gens très vif avec un idéal
très fort mais à partir de là il fallait
qu'ils imaginent à partir de la
partition mais aussi à partir de textes
à partir de leur instrument
ce que ça avait pu être et qu'elle était
peut-être l'idéal des anciens enfin
c'est pas que les notes c'est pas que la
proposition c'est beaucoup de choses
qui se passionnent pour cette musique il
y a le côté technique musique
il y a aussi un côté un peu chercheur
découvreur
oui oui historien
a beaucoup de d'importance moi je veux
dire que je suis assez peu musicologue
de temps en temps un texte gratuit mon
attention j'aime ça c'est très important
c'est une clé pour ceci cela et dans
l'ensemble je laisse un peu faire les
autres je dois dire mais il y a
énormément de compositeurs qui ont été
mis au goût du jour et qu'on a retrouvé
par exemple le Centre de Musique Baroque
de Versailles un énorme travail sur leur
bibliothèque où il y a toute la musique
française et alors on sort toujours des
nouveaux compositeurs quand on joue plus
depuis trois ou quatre siècles et des
fois on ferait mieux de les laisser
dormir mais le mauvais compositeur ou le
compositeur de moyen ou convention
conventionnelle de l'époque nous apprend
aussi beaucoup pour jouer la musique du
génie ou alors on comprend la musique du
génie qui parle le même longueur même
langage que le médiocre voilà on
mieux le génie et ce qui a surpris aussi
à l'époque pourquoi des composants
reconnus de leur temps parce que ça
allait trop loin
dans les dans les
je pensais c'est vrai que je crois qu'il
y a un opéra par exemple de Philippe
d'Orléans je ne savais pas que Philippe
d'Orléans avait écrit
pas mal pas mal du tout pas mal du tout
après c'est bon
c'était pas génial
mais ça veut dire ça nous montre que
quand même que ces gens oui il y avait
une culture
et souvent ça prenait beaucoup de place
et le roi de Prusse on va parler de lui
il avait vraiment ses musiciens les
meilleurs le fils de Bach courage qui
lui apprenait la flûte des instruments
merveilleux il invitait le vieux bac à
venir une fois le visiter ou absolument
le connaître etc
ça allait très loin dans la connaissance
bien sûr c'est
la guerre à côté aussi
donc je pensais oui faites l'amour pas
la guerre en fait la musique pas la
guerre mais
alors on a parlé de bac évidemment mais
dans vos musiciens de chevet je peux
dire il y a quoi escarlatine alors
scarlatine m'a pris pas mal de temps m'a
beaucoup intéressé je l'ai joué
peut-être plus que d'autres classes
sinistres qu'il avait un peu délaissé je
voyais et voilà ça vient du fait je
pense qu'il a un langage unique il est
un peu seul dans son coin à développer
quelque chose en dehors du monde parce
que il faut dire qu'à l'époque justement
les le langage était
quelque chose quand même bien commun
c'est à dire ce que je disais bon et des
mauvais compresseurs
les très grands compositeurs bac Mozart
respectaient enfin
ne n'était pas des révolutionnaires dans
le sens où ils envoyaient tout promener
ils utilisaient le langage de leur corps
mais de manière extraordinaire dans les
scarlatismes
est un peu en dehors de son temps il
fait des trouvailles avant les autres et
ils développent son langage mais je n'ai
pas connu cet homme mais je pense qu'il
y avait quelque chose d'un peu
particulier chez vous parce qu'il
utilise des choses
de manière très curieux répètent il se
répète
sur lui-même tout le temps d'accord il
dit une chose il a dit deux fois il a
dit trois fois et ça tourne et ça tourne
et donc ça n'est pas vraiment un langage
au sens syllabique
c'est autre chose ça tourne et ça ça
résonne et donc c'est plutôt des la
recherche de timbres de climat variés
comme ça et ça ça nous fait plutôt
penser à la suite de l'histoire de la
musique c'est curieux
oui il y a des auteurs moins connus
aujourd'hui
l'oncle Couperin lui Couperin
il y aura berger fresco Baldy des gens
comme ça qui était très important cette
époque toujours mais et là moi je me
suis intéressé beaucoup à la l'école
anglaise c'est la première école de
classe c'était un musicien
petit composteur anglais mais qui me
plaît bien et ça c'est autour de 1600 un
peu avant un peu après
justement ce qu'on parle de disque il y
a vous avez une œuvre discographie mais
vous préférez presque les concernant ou
ça dépend des
oui je préfère la musique vivante le
moment de partage de transmission si on
veut mais bon le disque transmet aussi
différemment mais c'est moins un partage
oui et alors ce moment du conseil c'est
quelque chose qui est quand même très
mouvement la musique à la maison quand
on joue pour des gens qu'ils soient une
deux trois dix ou sans ou 500 personnes
c'est quand même on essaie que ce soit
au moment
unique
c'est forcément unique mais éphémère par
exemple je veux pas que mes concerts
soient enregistrés d'accord
je fais les disques et les concerts pour
moi c'est tout autre exercé
de toucher les gens immédiatement si à
des micros qui sont là je vais penser au
micro je vais jouer comme pour un disque
c'est autre chose il y a une musique
évidemment un film qui a fait beaucoup
pour la pour cette musique baroque c'est
tous les matins du monde vous avez
vu c'est beaucoup d'influence et c'est
drôle même parce que je vais au prochain
concert
va se tenir dans l'église où on a
enregistré la musique de
bois
la plupart de la musique de tous les
matins du monde dans une petite église
très tranquille ce petit village
alors on va peut-être parler quand même
de cet instrument oui
le Club Saint
la définition la spécificité de du
clavecin si vous pouvez
grattées comme on gratte à la guitare
enfin la guitare avec le doigt ou alors
avec un mais plus quand on utilise un
plâtre
le doigt un intermédiaire et on gratte
et donc le clavecin fait partie la
famille pour moi des desistres des de la
harpe de la lutte de la guitare c'est un
instrument à cordes
du piano les cordes sont grattées le
piano c'est un instrument c'est le même
instrument au début on construit les
problèmes pianos dans un clavecin enfin
c'était la même classe mais on a mis ce
système de marteau qui frappe la corde
et qui échappe tout de suite c'est à
dire qu'il ne tient pas parce que sinon
ça va être tout frais c'est un coût très
bref doux au fort bien sûr et après la
corde résonne le marteau et le donc ce
procédé il a été
perfectionné tout le 18e siècle Enfin
sectionner on a commencé à travailler
sérieusement dessus au début du 18e
c'est Bartolome Bartolomeo Christophori
un florentin
au début c'était un peu ça marchait pas
encore bien etc petit à petit ça
marchait mieux c'est comme les avions et
pourquoi je dis ça
par exemple
des ailes en papier
mais donc voilà le piano c'est ça le
procédé du marteau existait des siècles
avant on le sait maintenant par des donc
ils avaient déjà inventé ces instruments
qui instruments à cordes et puis il y
avait un système de marteau qui était ça
a été un peu abandonné pendant des
siècles et il y a encore un orgue qui
est bien connu c'est ce sont des flûtes
autant de flûte que de tous de touche
mais comme il y a plusieurs registres
c'est multiplier par le nombre de
registres et donc c'est de l'air qui au
lieu de passer de la bouche dans une
flûte le système etc qui va dans le
tuyau et donc on a adapté à ces
instruments
peut-être pour les faire jouer plus
facilement
des claviers parce que l'invention quand
même génial c'est le clavier qui permet
de jouer comme un orchestre et alors
donc on a mis un clavier sur le système
c'est le clavecin on a mis un clavier
sur l'instrument qui avait les trucs à
marteau c'est du piano et sur les flûtes
de 2500 fumétistes
avec la vie un gros instrument voilà
c'est ça le clavier puisque vous parlez
du clavier il est plus petit que
peut-être de vous
en tout cas
l'ambitus oui parce que l'histoire la
musique c'est comme ça ça a commencé
comme ça c'est ce qu'on voit sur les
tableaux devant Nike
avec
on joue des petits orgues avec un
clavier à la main l'autre côté on
souffle en noir et un petit clavier qui
fait une octave une Octavie et puis tout
ça ça s'avançait mais c'est d'ailleurs
possible
[Musique]
je vois tout le temps chez bac aussi
on évite des notes qui n'existent pas
dans le texte alors voilà ça fait comme
ça
et
il y a combien d'octaves à l'heure dans
un club comme ça 1 2 3 4 et pas tout à
fait 5 mais il y a deux clavier
on va expliquer un peu le fonctionnement
alors là on est devant un de vos
clavecin voilà c'est un clavecin le
clavier basé plus ou moins plus ou moins
sur un clavecin allemand
début 18e qui est différent de l'autre
qu'on a vu
et comme beaucoup de clavecins
au 18e ils avaient deux claviers
d'accord les deux claviers ne sont pas
essentiels
c'est-à-dire qu'on a
sur cet instrument on a plus ou moins
trois clavecins dans un parce qu'on a
trois registres alors
sous cette pièce se trouve les rangées
de ce qu'on appelle des sauterons
le Sautron c'est cette pièce de bois qui
est posée sur la touche
dans laquelle il y a une autre pièce de
bois qui elle peut pivoter
une petite un petit feu pour étouffer le
son une fois qu'on veut l'arrêter et
dans cette pièce de bois il y a une
plume normalement une plume d'oiseau
d'ailleurs vous récolter des plumes
quand vous pouvez
c'est important pour nous c'est
éclaircissisme d'avoir toujours
parce qu'il faut les changer de temps en
temps c'est voilà comme c'est le
matériel naturel ça ça
vieillit modifie avec le temps et donc
ça c'est dont on a parlé c'est-à-dire
c'est l'équivalent du plecre de la qu'on
utiliserait sur une mandoline guitare
donc cette petite pièce et là c'est ça
qui gratte voilà et c'est elle qui
[Musique]
utilise un qui est blanc qui est pas du
de la plume parce qu'on voit mieux à
l'image mais quand on appuie sur la
touche on fait monter le sauter et
le spectre
produit le son parce qu'il gratte
exactement la même chose que si je fais
avec l'angle
ah oui voilà et d'ailleurs vous avez
entendu c'est comme sur une guitare si
je le fais ici je n'ai pas le même son
que là ici c'est plus rond plus flûté si
c'est un peu plus acide nasale
parce qu'il y a plusieurs timbres donc
il y a celui-ci qui est
comme ça l'autre est un peu pardon un
peu plus rond mais il est pas très loin
donc la différence n'est pas considérée
qui fait jouer l'un ou l'autre c'est ça
absolument il y en a un sur chaque
clavier
mais il pourrait être sur le même
clavier aussi
on a un autre jeu qui est un jeu
d'Octave
donc dans un registre qu'on enclenche
chacune manette voilà mais ici les
plectre sont éloignés de l'accord donc
il la font pas vibrer mais quand on l'a
on le met en phase comme ça ils vont
pincer aussi et donc c'est ce sont là
[Musique]
et dans l'octave supérieur voilà à ici
totalement faux depuis longtemps donc
j'accorde le 4 pieds
[Rires]
[Musique]
avec les deux autres jeux qui sont pas
très juste non plus
là on a les différents
[Musique]
qui est l'octave
je décompose en appuyant lentement
les trois jeux en fonction de la voilà
force avec laquelle vous appuyez
pour vous montrer mais si vous voulez si
je joue avec vitesse
je l'ai fait pincer tous les trois
ensemble voilà et donc c'est une
possibilité de registrer comme un orgue
parce que on essaie d'avoir des timbres
différents et aussi parce que le
clavecin ne permet pas justement cette
dynamique extrême qu'on a sur le piano
par exemple mais ça demande au club
cynisme de savoir
de connaître tout son instrument c'est
mieux alors là on a alors là c'est pour
montrer que justement on n'a pas besoin
des deux clavier c'est un plus mais ça
c'est alors ça c'est mon seul instrument
ancien
qui est un petit clavecin italien
anonyme on ne sait pas dater mais c'est
certainement première partie du XVIIe
siècle c'est très ancien très très
ancien et
on le voit par certains détails la
rosace etc donc il a été restauré et sur
celui-là j'ai deux jeux de ce que
j'appelle le jeu de huit pieds qui sont
à la même hauteur alors j'ai oublié
d'expliquer le huit pieds c'est une
terminologie de facteurs d'orgue c'est à
dire le
sur un orgue le tuyau qui produit son un
do grave
[Musique]
qui est la dernière note sur l'orgue et
ici aussi d'ailleurs
mesure 8 pieds
et donc c'est un peu la hauteur de
comme ça voilà et le 4 pieds est un jeu
une octave au dessus
parce que le jeu bien sûr l'autographe
quatre pieds ici il y a pas de 4 pieds
il y a deux jeux de huit pieds et je
peux les jouer ensemble
[Musique]
je veux pas qu'on enregistre mes
conseils mais là vous ne faites un
cadeau un tout petit prélude de Bach
c'est des pièces qui la composent
avec tout ce toute son âme mais dans un
but pédagogique pour ces jeunes élèves
pour cette seconde femme pour ses fils
quand il s'occupait beaucoup donc des
petites pièces
qui étaient progresser pédagogiques si
on veut mais je sais pas finalement chez
lui tout est quelque part pédagogiques
et tout est pour les déplacements
en ré mineur
[Musique]
bravo et merci beaucoup c'est un moment
comme ça pour nous merci infiniment
vous êtes vous avez un site
oui oui on tape mon
nom.fr
merci à Philippe merci
[Musique]